According to the Pentagon, no.
Rod first detected
this latest unidentified unmanned object
over Alaska on Friday evening
as they monitored it
and tracked where it was going.
It did cross into Canadian
airspace space.
At some point today, President Biden
and Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau
both spoke
they had both been
monitoring the situation
for the last 24 hours,
and they ultimately decided
that out of an abundance of caution.
They wanted to follow the advice
of their military leaders
and authorize
the shooting down of this object.
Now, at this point was
this operation was underway.
It was ultimately an American F-22
fighter jet
that shot down
this unidentified object over Canada.
Though there are still so many questions
about what exactly
this object
entailed, includes including the size,
its origin and its purpose.
And a few moments ago,
the defense minister of Canada
talked a little bit
about what they know at this moment.
That
recovery operations are now underway
and will be supported
by the Canadian
Armed Forces in conjunction with the RCMP
This coordinated operation
will allow a further investigation
into this object.
We have no further details
about the object at this time,
other than it appears
to be a small cylindrical object
and smaller than the one that was downed
off the coast. Of North Carolina.
There is no reason to believe
that the impact of the object
in Canadian territory
is of any public concern.
Now, there's some details
that she shared there
that they felt were different
from the object that was downed
just last week.
It's also worth noting that the object
that was over
off the Alaskan coast yesterday
and then today, that those are flying
at about 40,000 feet
at that point,
there is some concern
that there could be some impact
for civilian aircraft.
Now, just to recap,
there's this object today.
Yesterday
there was another unidentified object
near the coast of Alaska
that President Biden ordered
had to have shot down.
And then just one week prior,
we were here talking about that
suspected Chinese spy balloon
that was off the Carolina coast,
that President Biden had order
shot down as well.
Now, there still
are so many questions
about these latest
two unidentified objects
and who exactly
they belong to, whether it's a country,
whether it's a private entity right now
with a focus
will be is on the recovery missions
for both
the one that was shot down today
and the one shot down yesterday
to try to determine as much information
as they possibly can
be can about their origin.
And also the purpose
All right.
Arlette Signs,
we know you'll stay on top of it.
Thanks so much.
Joining us now to talk about this,
you know,
transportation analyst Mary Schiavo.
She's also a former
inspector general for the Department
of Transportation.
Mary, where do we begin? Let's see.
I guess let's start with
some of the information
that was coming
from the Canadian defense minister
just a few moments ago, because I have
you know,
I listened to that press conference
and I had lots of questions.
First of all,
this Canadian defense
minister said that the object
that is, I guess, of interest
here in all of this
that was shot down
over the skies
in Canada
earlier today was cylindrical and shaped.
That was the.
That is the exact words you used.
She said cylindrical and shape.
She said it was flying
at about 40,000 feet.
Going back to the conversation
you and you and
I had earlier, this evening,
you can't have objects
flying
that low could get in the way
of civilian aircraft, obviously.
But what is your sense of it,
listening to that kind of information?
Particularly the shape of this object?
That is very odd.
Well, it's very odd.
You know,
if you're looking for
a traditional balloon or an aircraft
but throughout history,
there have been many cylindrical
flying objects.
Okay.
Not to mention dirty balls.
And there have been rigid form bolts.
They don't have to be just a
gossamer balloon, so to speak.
So the fact that no one has reported
that the object took evasive
action
suggests that perhaps
it was not being remotely controlled.
Perhaps it was moving
with the winds, etc.
But right now,
it could be a lot of things.
Not to mention,
as I mentioned before,
it could be a rigid form
form of a balloon or other object
that had been used
both by the United States
and other countries in the past.
What I guess
one of the questions that I have very is
why is it here we are about a day,
more than a day after this
object was shot down
off the coast of Alaska.
We still haven't
been told any information
as to the specifics of what
that object was.
And, you know,
then we have this other object
shot down today that it's very peculiar.
Right.
Well, I can tell
you from firsthand experience
since I've been up here working in Alaska
for about two weeks
on another plane case, aircraft case,
the weather is really bad,
not bad per se.
There's just a lot of snow.
It's a bit windy.
It's very cold. It's very foggy.
So between the snow
and the fog
and you're trying to lie land on,
they said it was a
you know, an ice pack and ice island,
even for our great
aviators and and seafarers and the U.S.
military. That's tough.
And so the weather here
is rather obscured, so to speak.
And the snow is coming down
heavily in Anchorage.
So it may just be that
they can't
get to this object in a safe way
and that
this is just a dicey kind of operation
to go and inspect it.
Because what Natasha Bertrand, our
our national security
reporter, was telling us earlier
on this program
was that the pilots
who were trying to fly up
close to this object in Alaska yesterday
were having different accounts,
offering different accounts
as to what they saw.
So I suppose the elements, to your point,
might be a factor in all of this.
Right.
Visibility is rather poor.
I mean, I'm working
very close to an airport.
And believe me, it's
all IFR instrument
flight operations right now.
Planes that are taking off,
they disappear into the clouds
very quickly,
especially with snow coming down.
So the fact that the pilots couldn't
identify it, particularly
as it was, for example,
a rigid form of an air ship,
you know, a dirigible, so to speak.
Yeah,
they wouldn't have had any occasion
to see those over the last decade or so
a couple of decades.
So I think that they're
just having difficulty actually
getting eyes on
and the equipment
that they used to shoot them down
obviously does not depend
upon human eyes to have eyes on.
They have the ability to do that,
you know, with their or their computers.
So I think that the visibility is
a big issue up here.
All right,
Mary Schiavo,
thanks so much for springing into action
for us.
So we've added additional hour of
CNN NEWSROOM this evening.
We appreciate it.
Paula Newton joins me on the phone.
Paula, I guess, you know,
you and I had just a brief
couple of moments to parse
through what
the Canadian defense
minister was saying
during that press conference.
But I want to go back and reiterate
what she said
just about 20 or 30 minutes ago
and that is
that this object was flying
at about 40,000 feet.
It was over the Yukon Territory
and that it was some it was in.
So it was cylindrical.
It was a small cylindrical object,
which obviously sounds very strange.
But as Mary Schiavo was saying,
there might be some
perfectly fine explanations for that.
But your impressions
as to how much information
you're getting
from the Canadian side of things,
we're not getting a whole lot
from the American side at this point.
Yeah, no.
And if
officials wanted
to get ahead of this, obviously,
because it was shot down over
Canadian airspace
and it was up to them
to make these kinds of pronouncements,
really to say what was shot
down, exactly what was going
on, and the fact that it was shot down
four and a half hours ago
now and that they were going through
the debris
field to try and ascertain what it is.
I think there were a couple
of significant things.
And I think and Anita
Anand, the defense minister,
saying that it was at 40,000 feet.
Right.
And that gives us some explanation
as to why they decided
that it had to be brought down now.
We're showing a map right now of Yukon
that is a huge territory.
She said it was shot down
in central Yukon.
You know, it's going to take a while
to really determine where it came down,
even though they I'm sure
they had line of sight on it.
But to obviously
pick it up and then analyze it.
This is going to be a joint operation
it is obviously Canadian forces right now
that are doing that kind of
that kind of investigation right now.
But in conjunction
with the RCMP, Canada's
national police force,
and in fact, the FBI and U.S.
forces as well.
So was it
the same kind of object
that was shot down over
Alaska by the United States?
Might have been.
I think many questions right now would be
that the minister, Anita
Anand, went out of her way
to say to us, Jim,
that this was unprecedented
and unprecedented action
on the part of Norway
to shoot something like this down
over Canadian airspace.
The question she did not answer
was whether or not
they had seen
objects like this before in their radar.
She went on to say,
obviously, that they're going
to be really beefing up
their surveillance.
There that does involve
an entire new security infrastructure
up there
that they have been working on for years.
But also, Jim,
want to point out
something that Secretary Austin said
after meeting
with Defense Minister
Ananda in Washington just yesterday
and that he referenced
the increasing assertiveness of China.
Now, while they were talking about China
because of the spy balloon
that was shot down off
the Carolina coast,
at issue is that they know
they have other actors
in the Arctic Russia being just one.
And they do see a more robust
defense structure
that needs to be put in place there.
But I thought that language was quite
strong on
the part of the secretary saying
it was Anita Anand together.
That is is this this assertiveness
that bothers them.
So certainly a menacing factor.
Now, three
objects, high
altitude and taking action on all three.